So that's your minimum intervening scheduling policy that
is ensuring that the processor that is picked
for T i to run on has the
highest affinity for T i. That's the minimum intervening.
And there's a variant of minimum intervening, which
is called limited min, minimum intervening, which is essentially
saying that if I have let's say, 1,000
processes in the multiprocessor then the amount of information
that I want to keep for every one of these
threads is huge, right? For every processor that is
available in the multiprocessor, I need to keep this
affinity index for this thread. At maybe too much meta
data that this scheduler has to maintain on behalf
of every thread. And therefore, that means there's a variant
of minimum intervening which is called limited minimum intervening.
Which is saying, don't keep this infinity index for all
the processors. Just keep it for the top
few processors. So if the infinity index, if it
is two or three, those are the ones that I care about. If the infinity index is
20 or 30 I'm not going to pick that,
so why bother keeping all of the affinity index
for a particular thread? Just keep the top candidates.
That's the idea behind limited minimum intervening scheduling policy.
The last policy I'm going to introduce you to. It's called
Minimum Intervening Plus Queueing. The idea is still the same
that I want to look at whether Intervening Threads that
ran on a particular processor with respect to this thread
that I am trying to schedule at this point of
time. But when I make a scheduling decision that Ti
is going to run on a particular processor It may be
that this particular processor Pj may already have some other threads
that are going to run on it, and that's the
idea behind minimum intervening plus queue. Again, I want to explain
this in a little bit more detail. So in
minimum intervening scheduling plus queuing wouldn't be the same as
It's not only the affinity index of Ti with
respect to a particular processor I'm going to look at, but
I'm also going to look at the queue for this particular
processor. Why do we need to know do that? Well,
if Ti is going to be scheduled on,
on this particular processor PJ. Maybe there's a
scheduling queue associated with PJ, which already has
some number of threads to be run. And
therefore, even though I'm picking the process of
PJ based on cash affinity. By the time
TI gets to actually run. Two other threads
are going to run before it, so this was
when Ti ran last, and I might find the
definitive for Ti with respect to Pj, is two,
just like in this previous example that I gave
you, the affinity is two, so it looks like
a good choice to put ti on, on pj, if this turns out to be There are the
minimum, but when I made that decision, what I'm
going to do is I'm going to stick this thread Ti in
the scheduling queue of Pj and if the scheduling queue of Pj has Tm and Tn
already populated, then what's going to happen Time is
now, but by the time Ti gets to
run on the process of Pj, Tm and Tn would also have run on the processor. Right?
So even though the affinity index that I computed at the point of the scheduling
decision, the scheduling decision, at the scheduling decision I made the
decision to put Ti on Pj based on its affinity with respect to
processor Pj. But unfortunately, the reality is that Ti is not going to
run immediately, but it is going to run much later
in time, and by the time it gets to
run, two other threads that are already sitting in
the Q of Pj, they're going to run. And therefore,
the cache will be more polluted [LAUGH] than what
we thought it was going to be at this point
of time. So that's the reason that this scheduling
policy's called minimum intervening plus Q, saying that. Not only
should you ta, take into account the affinity index
of a thread with respect to a particular processor, but
you should also look at the Q of the
processor. And ask the question, is the Q already populated?
In that case, the, the processor that I want to pick Ti to run on is the min
of i plus q where i if the affinity index and q is the size
of the scheduling q associated with this particular
processor pj. So that's the last scheduling policy.
So basically have introduced five different scheduling policies,
first come first serve. Fixed processor, last processor,
minimum intervening, and minimum intervening plus queuing and as
I mentioned, these two scheduling policies will really not be
having the information for a thread with respect to all
the processors in the system, because in a large scale
process it may be invisible to do that. So
what you do is, you limit the amount of information
that you keep for every one of these threads. Remember
one of the attributes of a good operating system is
to make a decision really quickly and get out of
the way, and from that point of view the less
information it has to sift through in order to make
a scheduling decision, the faster it can do it's work.